welcome to Hannity we have big breaking
news on multiple fronts tonight the
people are speaking loud and clear and
the reopening America of America whether
some states like it or not is well
underway businesses are now opening with
safety measures in place NASCAR is back
golf is beginning to come back the
ratings are massive Wow wonder why major
progress in the race for a vaccine a bio
tech giant moderna is now seeing
promising results human testing actually
creating antibodies we'll talk more
about it also we'll review the lessons
learned from the successes of Florida
Texas the failures of New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania Michigan plus we
will reveal the countdown of all
countdowns let's just say it has to do
with the ever so forgetful Joe Biden in
his basement we'll have the very latest
from his floundering campaign and also
we're gonna play new sound from that
whole phony hypocrite Barack Obama it'll
make your blood boil because he's really
describing himself and we start tonight
with good news we are now seeing major
advancements in the development of a
vaccine for Kovan 19 this biotech
company moderna human trials are now
yielding extremely positive results it's
early but moderna CEO said that the
initial study could not have been any
better the trial vaccine is said to be
generally safe and well tolerated among
participants who responded to the
vaccine by producing a high number of
antibodies with a relatively low dose
we'll explain also a vaccine is still
there may not be a long way out but it's
a terrific development from our top
scientists we know they will get us out
of this and any other pandemic we have
other good news Americans have now
decided that this country is reopening
they're taking matters into their own
hands look at your screen this is the
American brilliance ingenuity creativity
at its best Hair Salons reopening with
the use of mass and other PPE look at
this with casinos they are now literally
constructing clear
barriers that enable gamblers with six
feet different social distancing to
return to the tables their nail salons
are shielding employees and customers
with Plexiglas and of course gloves and
masks one gym in New Jersey conducting
mandatory temperature temperature checks
this gym is bucking a state lockdown
order in New Jersey and reopening all
the way but as you're about to see these
state mandates are becoming more and
more meaningless because people are not
listening they seem to have made up
their own mind and it's not an agreement
with these governors that did a
particularly awful job take a look all
right that one gym in New Jersey is just
one of many businesses now fighting back
against these state lock downs in the
state of Michigan yeah you can't cut
your lawn for a while medical centers
they have now sued governor Whitmer with
her ban on medical services that she
deems non-essential Kentucky's
Democratic governor sued for restricting
church services even with social
distancing and masks and following a
suit in the great state of Wisconsin
their Supreme Court struck down its safe
at home mandates by the way California
now beginning to face dozens of lawsuits
over constitutional infringement what
we're witnessing is the beginning to the
end of state lock downs it looks like
people watched they listened they they
quarantine they sheltered in place and
they decided where the risks are and
tonight we know what it will take we
learn a lot of lessons from states and a
lot of bad lessons from other states we
learn from the success in Florida in
Texas they focus their response on
isolating at-risk communities nursing
homes long-term care facilities
retirement homes look at your screen
these are the stats from Florida and Tex
with a combined population over 50
million residents including a huge
elderly population though the two states
have accounted for fewer than 4,000
total deaths about 80,000 total cases
that is far less than the state of
Michigan by comparison you can see that
the state of New York reported three
hundred and forty thousand cases
approximately thirty thousand deaths
some 33 percent of those coming from
nursing homes because instead of
isolating nursing homes long-term care
facilities like they did in Florida and
they did in Texas New York governor
issued an executive order his was March
25th forcing these nursing homes to
admit kovat 19 positive patients now
around 30 percent of the death toll is
from these facilities and despite only
recently withdrawing this disastrous
order o cuomo is totally unapologetic
imagine if donald trump said the
following older people vulnerable people
are going to die from this virus that is
going to happen despite whatever you do
because with all our progress as a
society we can't keep everyone alive
despite what everything you do and older
people are more in spite of what you do
we covet 19 let's send them into the
areas where the people of the sickest
and most vulnerable
that was a dumb idea imagine a president
Trump then said that now despite
whatever you do well if you did what
Florida did and you did what Texas did
yeah they did a lot better but anyway
despite what you do okay you mean like
forcing nursing homes to take in
patients infected with coronavirus when
they were totally unprepared we're
screaming they're unprepared and instead
of admitting them to the USNS comfort or
the Javits Center they only used a
thousand of the 3,000 beds they're only
a hundred and eighty two beds on the
hospital ship well guess what
they remain largely unused that was
Governor Cuomo Wolfe Whitmer Murphy New
Jersey they made the dumbest decisions
and they did not protect the elderly and
the mo
vulnerable Florida and Texas did those
executive orders by these four states
that failed helped us learn what not to
do New York California they are now
demanding red states also pay off their
massive debt now the two states that
have the highest income taxes in the
entire country here's some how drowning
in debt for comparison Florida in Texas
no income tax and by the way no debt and
they managed to balance their budget
make no mistake responsible residents
who live in red states in no way should
you be forced to pay off the unfunded
pensions sanctuary state policies
massive entitlements reckless wasteful
spending on new Green Deal nonsense
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars of waste and we'll have a lot
more on that with Texan Texas Governor
Abbott in a second but first we turn to
more breaking news from the president
who just announced that he's been taking
hydroxychloroquine as a prophylactic
treatment to prevent cope in nineteen
for over a week
predictably the mob the media the now
hyperventilating over those remarks ever
since President Trump mentioned what
have you got to lose hydroxychloroquine
for its possible benefits months ago all
the mob of the media they have been
waging what is an unhinged non-stop
never-ending PR campaign against it they
acted like the president and his hope
and optimism about the drug were some
type of mortal sin they called him
reckless and irresponsible no that would
be your fellow Democratic governors they
screwed up Trump built the hospitals man
the hospitals and sent them all the
medical equipment they needed now the
President himself he's made a decision
along with his doctors to take
hydroxychloroquine as a preventive
treatment of course this drug is
something we have covered extensively on
this program it has been used to treat
malaria lupus rheumatoid arthritis for
over 65 years and now it's being tested
as a potential treatment potential
prophylactic on coronavirus because so
few patients with lupus and rheumatoid
arthritis were contracting kovat one
expert probably the world's expert on
hydroxychloroquine he is a renowned
board-certified rheumatologist Cedars
Sinai Medical Center his name after 40
what two years of practice Daniel
Wallace he has treated thousands of
patients with lupus rheumatoid arthritis
etc since 1985 he issued a letter
recently about the treatment writing
hydroxychloroquine is a very safe drug
it has been given to tens of millions of
individuals in the world since its
approval in 1955 that's 65 years ago in
42 years a practice no patient of mine
has ever been hospitalized for any
complication this doctor has authored
over 400 peer-reviewed studies was a
principal author of the textbook on
lupus and he said the risk is nil and
the doses and the time frame were
talking about as it relates to the
treatment of Cova 19 I'm not a doctor
I'm not advising you to take the drug
but that guy with those credentials he
seems like the foremost expert in the
country I take his word for it so you
can stay informed know the risk
consult with your doctor and you
ultimately decide and despite what the
mob and the Democrats believe Americans
they're smart people they're tired of
the lies Asteria conspiracy theories
coming from the media every second
minute hour of every 24-hour day
Americans are sick and tired of this BS
one local reporter in Long Island well
he captured all of this on his Twitter
live feed didn't go particularly well
for him take a look
[Music]
I think people are allowed to speak out
in America some people get upset when
Americans speak out it is hard to be
sympathetic to the mainstream media mob
considering all the mob does is think
that Americans well respect them but
after years and years of lies and
slander and hoaxes and conspiracy
theories yeah their credibility is zero
and remember it dozens of presidents
Trump's rallies remember the people in
the crowd they were pretty loud and
clear with their critiques what they
think of fake news
take a look enn which is so bad and so
pathetic and their ratings are going
down
[Applause]
CNN sucks that was pretty loud and it
happened a number of times why because
they're fake news they do suck and they
do have a political agenda kind of that
simple now by the way to that end they
will do whatever it takes to defeat
President Trump in the fall